tout le monde ou presque connaît
mireille un petit bout de bonne femme
très énergique qui fête aujourd'hui ses
90 printemps 70 ans de chansons
également les plus anciens se
souviennent de son petit conservatoire
télévisé qui a vu passer bien des stars
de la chanson d'aujourd'hui avec jean
nohain
elle a composé plus de 600 refrain
empruntant le petit chemin pour se
coucher dans le foin jordan le chemin
semé de succès de michail à christine a
commencé disons il ya bien longtemps
pourtant ces centaines de chansons ne
prennent pas de rides
mireille fait chanter les générations et
les interprètes de prestige et well
exemple un ensemble de tous les sl est
il à leur fin 1955 mireille se lancent à
la rtf le petit conservatoire de la
chanson 72 celle qui donne le la donne
des bonnes notes un élément prometteur
je suis content de vous retrouver dans
la classe voisine eu à bhl avec sa
coiffure inventé pour elle par colette
mireille un quart de siècle plus tard
avec pascal sevran devenue grands
garçons dans cette pépinière imaginé par
sacha guitry
elle découvre des dizaines de talent
françoise hardy jean jacques debout
hugues aufray à la souchon serge lama
yves duteil alice dona michel berger
safou julien clerc et bien d'autres
la vidéo mireille se balancent entre
l'ère du piano et les paroles couché
dans le foin